ああああ
ああ
a
本物とあですね
その民族がですね関係するための詩
meme まあこれは文化ですねっ
日本人の場合は宇宙や自然だと思います
エアーこれはべ目 deno だけじゃ
なくてええ
辺のさえずりとか
顔長へ
風の塔
こういうハメ二分の一の揺らぎを表現した
若ドバイ存在したと思います
9捕
あの
今後
取り付け
まあ
肌まで方ですね形で行く人とエアー体で
覚える人これはの2種類をが出ると思うん
ですけど私はもうなあかんを再種類
行き着く先あるぜ異色のだと思うんですよ
で
金思えるそのちょうど症としましては
トレカがもう全然70点取れるんですね
そのこの
かなって言わですねまぁその経済やですね
構成のを保つために
吸った迫り訳なんですね上がり水エヴァ
まあ url を作ることによって誰もが
系筋トレを取れる区
これが方なんですよ
これもすごいやろう
すごい外れようと思ってるんですけどねぇ
えええ
どういう人でもそれを南下するほど言って
70点が取れるピュアすごくんですよ
ませぬいいじゃないですけどそういう
硬くはないですね作ったと母とまぁ方なん
ですけど
レーマーただですねはま子の短所待って
ちょっとしましては文字通り行っちゃっ
たら
逆に本質がズレちゃうというか
杓子定規行ったりとか
まあ語りやって使われてしまうんですねー
これがものすごいその弱点と思います
4を
あの体で覚えることですねー
ジャック体としましては
鳥高容量オーバー技なんですよ
で今3台あのスピーディーな違い時代に
なってきたら一つ boa の物事を習得
数誰にもう数時間かかるんですね
金を得ちゃったーーーー
ただその
長女しましてはですねー
を
その物事の本質に気づく
反復運動を繰り返すことによってですねー
税経ではですよ
無心の行事近くを入れですね
でこれも凄い凄いことでレイアあとあの
敬遠されがですね
の中に勝ち
残せなかった
行間の部分のボイスに気づいたりとか
それの場所のを掲載が他の人とかないわ
ですね
新しい号側縁を波形したりするんですよ
レスナーのもう
何ですか県債が他の人にとってはですね
もしかしたらその方はいらないかもしれ
ないですね
そういうであのー
私は墓地からではなくそう政治をション
蘇我
声帯が教えるのかを健康勉強する方なん
ですけど
で
1走って
絶対その丸い
そのは取っちゃダメなんですよで自分の
そう
皆さんの農繁とそういう本に書かれた内容
をミックスさせて新しい右形を作らないと
いけないですね
レスラーのそうこれは後ろその中国の村
ゲー数あるまあ同窓思想の総知っている方
がですね言ってるんですけどことごとく
ライム書物お子様したらその書物は未来を
言ってるです
これは本質的な事で
で a
[拍手]
今年だ言って
愛じゃないですかその答えがないじゃない
ですか
a
底材が無い中で
答え見やすい今後力が求められるんです
けどこれ現実だけであって全て a
あでもだと思うんですね
a こういうその
何さんそういう能力っていうを
でい
右つけるためには書いてその所もそう昔
ながら夫でずっとの歴史的な風雪に耐えて
残っているものですね勉強水っていうのは
すごくあると思います